the Internet's boyfriend's might be
speeding into one of the biggest movie
franchises out there in a recent
interview with screen rants longtime
fast and furious scribe Chris Morgan
revealed that he has spoken with Keanu
Reeves about joining the film series and
an upcoming entry presumably fast and
furious 9 which Morgan is co-writing
with Daniel Katie Morgan teased I sat
down with him and we're talking about it
I wanted him to be in the fast universe
for a very long time the hardest thing
is always time and competing schedules
and then designing the right thing
together my fervent desire is to bring
him into this franchise for sure Morgan
has indeed been hoping to make Reeves an
official member of the fast family for
quite some time and even got close to
making that dream a reality fairly
recently in August 2019
the rock Johnson said that Reeves could
have been in Hobson Shore the Fast and
Furious spin-off centered on Johnson's
character Luke Hobbs and his on-screen
frenemy Deckard Shaw played by Jason
Statham the actor told screen rants that
the original plan was to have Reeves
portray the director of the terrorist
organization at Ian's in Hobson Shore
written by you guessed it Chris Morgan
as Johnson explained things just didn't
work out and so the Hobson Shore team
decided to keep the identity of a Tian's
director a mystery by only revealing his
voice Johnson dished we left the ominous
voice faceless so for some time I think
you guys have heard the rumor that it
was going to be a bit of a John wek or
disguised but then we left it there with
a few people in mind originally Keanu
was the goal we were talking and it just
didn't feel right creatively he and I
talked and I totally got it and it wound
up being the best thing so now we leave
that open for the future
Hobson Shore director david leitch also
addressed the situation in an August
2019 interview with The Hollywood
Reporter the filmmaker explained that
the team quote talk tachyon Oh early on
and that he quote had been talking to
Keanu periodically through the shooting
of it all and was trying to decide how
best to include him in Hobson's sure in
the end though Hobson Shore just wasn't
the right film to introduce Reeves into
the Fast and Furious franchise you ready
yeah leech explained I also wanted to
make sure that it was enough a we all
promised for something that Jetta Mert
in the future and wasn't just a stunt
casting role we started to populate the
movie with all these other personalities
and I just didn't really think that we
needed it although I would have loved it
we even talked in post and I showed him
a rough cut of the movie then we had
conversations about is there something
here we came to the conclusion of let's
put a pin in it
I'm all for finding opportunities but I
also didn't want to force anything the
remarks from both Johnson and leach plus
a revelation from Morgan about having
had a chat with the actor make it seem
like Reeves could appear in Fast and
Furious 9 as a Tian's director but is
that really how he'll fit into the fast
family anything's possible of course
there was worth questioning whether that
particular role will ever be right for
reef's if it wasn't back then how would
it be now if Reeves truly well join fast
and furious 9 and he won't portray a
tianj director in the film the best bet
for the type of character he'll embody
as an antihero similar to John wick the
hired gun Reeves plays and the Derek
Kolstad created action thriller
franchise or and remember you owe me you
don't want me owing you the fast
franchise has plenty of protagonists the
most prominent of which is now Vin
Diesel's Dominic Toretto and has
featured a ton of down-and-dirty
villains but history has shown that the
characters who aren't entirely good or
completely bad are some of the more
interesting inclusions and the franchise
so it's possible that Morgan Casey and
fast line director Justin Lin might want
to have Reeves play a morally grey
character considering the Fast & Furious
franchise team has long been eyeing
Reeves to join in some capacity
it doesn't seem outrageous to say that
they want to place them in a role that
is not only interesting and well-rounded
but that also has true staying power
like leeched said we use potential role
in the film series should have promised
and legitimacy so that he can continue
being a part of the movies and the
future taking everything into account
it appears that Fast and Furious 9 just
might be the movie in which Reeves makes
his franchise debut and regardless of
who he may play in the flick his
appearance should be to quote the man
himself pretty damn dressed
fast and furious 9 will speed into
theaters on May 22nd 2020 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]